you're fula another fight in the car
that's very interesting is Henry cejudo
and Sergio Pettis Sergio Pettis is the
younger brother of Showtime Pettis
Anthony Pettis who is the former
lightweight champion and Henry cejudo of
course is a former Olympic gold medalist
the number two ranked flyweight in the
world and Henry is coming off of an
absolutely spectacular ko of Wilson
Hayes I was blown away by him in that
fight and that fight he looked like some
sort of a karate master I mean that was
a it was a very very interesting fight
before that he lost a bet Evita is and
Benavidez is of course one of the most
experienced one of the best guys in the
division and he lost a very very close
fight a fight where I've talked to his
coaches afterwards and they were really
pissed off by the decision they thought
sudo could have gotten an odd but he
rebounded and he rebounded versus Wilson
Hayes and looked like a completely
different fighter the thing that excites
me about this fight is two things one
the potential of Sergio Pettis Sergio
Pettis is a young kid he's one of the
youngest guys in the division he's the
extremely talented younger brother of
another extremely talented fighter so
he's had martial arts in his life you
know most of the time growing up he's 24
years old now he trained under the great
Duke Rufus who in my opinion is one of
the very best guys in the division in
terms of his ability to coach fighters
he's fantastic
Diouf not to division I mean I should
say in the in in the sport
Duke Rufus is just an amazing striking
coach he's a former world Muay Thai
champion himself outstanding kickboxer
and extremely knowledgeable about both
kick boxing and MMA and one of the best
guys in the world at training kick
boxers for MMA I mean he's just
fantastic and what we've seen from young
Sergio we saw him get submitted by Alex
casseras early on in his career
um and alex is just slicker and caught
them on the ground and and then we saw
him lose again to Ryan but no I I think
that these losses especially for a young
fighter are absolutely critical I think
you find out what you're really made of
you and you see what you need to improve
upon and in fighting tough guys early on
like Alex casseras
like Ryan Pinoys I mean and we're
talking about two years ago he fought
but knowing he was 21 years old so or 22
years old he's 24 now so he's a really
young kid still learning still growing
on the job and has looked fantastic in
his last few fights looked really good
against John Moraga and looked even
better against Brandon Moreno in his
last fight which was a five round
unanimous decision victory so this in my
opinion is gonna be the toughest fight
of his career because Henry cejudo just
has that Olympic gold medal winner
mindset the mindset of a galaxy' who doe
I mean this guy is focused on being a
champion 24 hours a day and if you look
at the way he fought against Wilson
Hayes I mean if that's indicative of the
kind of improvement that this guy can
make and carry and Fitzgibbons who is
another phenomenal muy Thai coach
he told me that this kid is just a
sponge and just can learn so fast at a
ridiculous way and I think you're
looking at athletic prowess in Henry
cejudo but I think maybe perhaps more
important than that you're looking at
his mind his mind is just ultra sharp
and focused and and determined and he's
just got that championship mindset I
mean that's why he was an Olympic gold
medalist in wrestling so he's got
unparalleled wrestling skill in the
division and then on top of that if you
look at the wilson hayes fight you look
at radical improvements in his striking
and movement i mean he looked like a
combination of a prime lyoto machida
and
McGregor vs. with his movement against
Wilson Hayes I think a lot of guys are
realizing that that karate style if you
have all those other bases covered if
you have great wrestling if you have
submissions good takedown defense and
good boxing skills as well as Muay Thai
everything else that karate stance that
sideways stance that we see employed all
the time by wonderboy Thompson that we
see we've seen a bunch of different
fighters of course lyoto machida a bunch
of different fighters use that stance
inside the Octagon Conor McGregor it's a
very difficult stance to deal with it's
if you're good at it if you're good at
that movement that in and out side to
side movement Michael venom page has a
very unusual take on that fighting in
Bellator he likes to fight like that too
and of course he's a former point
fighting champion that style is
hard to deal with it's really hard for
guys to judge and if you're dealing with
a guy like sudo who's lightning fast on
top of that and starts moving like that
with those world-class wrestling skills
with excellent striking you know classic
striking boxing kickboxing very
difficult to deal with I'm very
interested to see what style he takes or
how he approaches this fight was Sergio
Pettis he's quite a bit older than
Sergio being 30 that's a really
interesting fight I'm very curious I
just do not know how that one's going to
play out